N
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE ANSWERED
BY THE PRESIDENT.
THIS WAS NOT A INEVITABLE.
PEOPLE INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE --
OBVIOUSLY EXTREMELY CONCERNED
ABOUT HOW INEPTLY THEY ARE
HANDLING THIS SITUATION.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS LEAKED LEAKED
INFORMATION TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," WHICH
PUBLISHED THE EMBARRASSING
DETAILS ABOUT THE BIDENS TEAM
EMBARRASSING AT TIMES AND TO WOO
CHINA TO HELP US AVERT WAR IN
UKRAINE.
CHINA CHINESE OFFICIALS REBUFFED
THE AMERICANS, U.S. OFFICIALS
GOT INTEL SHOWING BEIJING HAD
SHARED INFORMATION WITH MOSCOW,
TELLING THE RUSSIANS THAT THE
UNITED STATES WAS TRYING TO SOW
DISCORD, AND THAT CHINA WOULD
NOT TRY TO IMPEDE RUSSIAN PLANS
AND ACTION.
THE VERY IDEA THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT THAT THEY
COULD GET ACT IN OUR INTEREST IS
DELUSIONAL.
THAT'S THE THINKING OF SOMEONE
WHO KNOWS LITERALLY NOTHING
ABOUT THE WAY OUR BIGGEST
ADVERSARY OPERATES.
YET, THAT HAS BEEN THE EXACT
MIND-SET OF BIDEN'S CHINA POINT
MAN FOR OVER A YEAR NOW.
>> CHINA HAS PRODUCED
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC GROWTH.
CHINA'S PARTNERSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE,
EXTRAORDINARY INTERNATIONAL
CONSEQUENCE, IS ESSENTIAL.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE, THE
UNITED STATES, THE SECOND
BIGGEST COMPETITOR AND CHINA AND
THE REST OF THE WORLD ARE ALL
PULLING TOGETHER IN THE SAME
DIRECTION IN THIS CRITICAL
EFFORT.
>> CLIMATE CHANGE!
JOHN KERRY HAS BEEN AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE COUNTRY
SINCE HE RETURNED FROM VIETNAM
TO CONDEMN HIS FELLOW TROOPS.
THIS IS JUST ONE MORE INSULT,
THIS TIME WITH HEAVY
CONSEQUENCES FOR AMERICA.
CHINA WAS NEVER GOING TO WORK
WITH US ON THE CLIMATE, ON
UKRAINE.
NOTHING THAT IS NOT IN ITSELF
INTEREST.
PERHAPS, BIDEN IS NOW REALIZING
THIS OBVIOUS FACT, WHICH WOULD
EXPLAIN HIS DEER IN THE
HEADLIGHTS LOOK WHEN HE WAS
ASKED ABOUT IT.
>> ARE YOU URGING CHINA TO HELP
ISOLATE RUSSIA?
>> President Biden: I'M NOT
PREPARED TO COMMENT ON THAT AT
THE MOMENT.
>> Laura: TRANSLATION?
"WE TRIED THAT AND IT FAILED."
IT HAS BACKFIRED.
CHINA AND RUSSIA NOW SEEM CLOSER
THAN EVER.
FIRST, CHINA REFUSED TO CALL
WHAT RUSSIA DID IN UKRAINE AND
INVASION.
THEN, THEY BLAMED US FOR THE
CARNAGE UNLEASHED.
TODAY, PRESIDENT XI PERSONALLY
OFFERED SUPPORT FOR RUSSIA ON A
CALL WITH PUTIN.
ACCORDING TO THE REIT DON'T
MIGRATE OUT, ALSO EXPRESSED THE
IMPORTANCE OF REJECTING A
COLD WAR MENTALITY, ADDING THAT
HE SERIOUSLY RESPECTS THE
REASONABLE SECURITY CONCERNS OF
ALL COUNTRIES.
THE FACT IS CHINA DOES NOT CARE
ABOUT PEOPLE BEING SLAUGHTERED
IN THE UKRAINE OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
LET'S NOT FORGET: CHINA FUNNELS
ENOUGH FUNDS IN ALL INTO OUR
COUNTRY EVERY YEAR TO KILL
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF OUR
CITIZENS.
THEY ARE COMMITTING, THEY
CRUSHED FREEDOM IN HONG KONG,
AND ARE NOW FUNDING PUTIN'S
CONQUEST OF UKRAINE BY BUYING UP
THEIR ENERGY AND EVEN THEIR
WHEAT.
IN MANY WAYS, THIS WAS MADE IN
CHINA, AND THE GOAL IS TO TEST
THE WATERS FOR AN ATTACK ON
TAIWAN.
ONCE XI THINGS HE CAN INVADE
TAIWAN, HE WILL.
RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE STEPS THAT
WE COULD AND SHOULD IMMEDIATELY
TAKE TO STOP THAT FROM BECOMING
AN INEVITABILITY, AND MAKE XI
MAY BE REALIZED THAT HE HAS
UNDERESTIMATED THE RESOLVE AND
STRENGTH OF AMERICA.
THESE ACTIONS COULD MAKE HIM
THINK TWICE ABOUT FURTHER
COOPERATION WITH RUSSIA.
WE NEED TO GRADUALLY BEGIN WHAT
WILL BE A VERY PAINFUL PROCESS,
BUT TO DECOUPLE FROM CHINA.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE ASTUTE
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP,
DETERMINATION, AND CONSUMER
SACRIFICE ON OUR PART.
THIS WILL INCLUDE D LINKING OUR
MANUFACTURING ON KEY TECHNOLOGY,
RAISING TARIFFS WHERE NECESSARY
TO PRESERVE MADE IN AMERICA, AND
CANCELING STUDENT VISAS.
ABOUT 340,000 CHINESE STUDENTS
STUDYING HERE RIGHT NOW.
WHY ARE WE TRAINING CHINA'S NEXT
GENERATION, ALL OF WHOM ARE
APPROVED TO BE HERE BY THE CCP?
WHY ARE WE TRAINING THEM IN STEM
FIELDS?
AT SOME POINT DOWN THE ROAD, WE
KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO TURN
AROUND AND USE WHAT THEY HAVE
LEARNED HERE AGAINST US OR OUR
ALLIES.
IN ORDER FOR AMERICA TO REGAIN
OUR LEVERAGE WITH CHINA AND
RUSSIA, WHICH WE NEED, WE HAVE
TO DROP THE NOTION THAT EITHER
WILL EVER CARE ABOUT ADHERING TO
A RULES-BASED INTERNATIONAL
ORDER THAT WE KEEP HERE IN
BLATHERING ABOUT.
THAT IS NOT JUST COOKED UP IN
THINK TANKS, LATER INVOKED BY
IGNORANT GLOBALISTS LIKE
JOHN KERRY.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE LONG
ARC OF CHINESE AND RUSSIAN
HISTORY TO UNDERSTAND THAT BOTH
PUTIN AND XI ARE BOTH
UNFAILINGLY RUTHLESS AND
SUPREMELY NATIONALISTIC.
MEANWHILE, THEY EXPLOIT WEAKNESS
WHEREVER THEY SEE IT, WHETHER
IT'S FINANCIAL OR CULTURAL.
RUSSIA AND CHINA RESPECT -- AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS SHOWN
THEM ONLY WEAKNESS FROM DAY ONE.
THEY ONLY RESPECT STRENGTH.
ONCE, WE WERE A DRIVER OF OUR
OWN FOREIGN POLICY, BUT NOW
UNDER BIDEN, WE TAKE CUES FROM
NATIONS THAT DON'T NECESSARILY
SHARE OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
PRIORITIES, LIKE GERMANY.
WE WERE ONCE PROUD OF, AS A
NATION, TO TEACH OUR CHILDREN
ABOUT THE BRILLIANCE AND
SACRIFICE OF OUR FOUNDERS, BUT
NOW IN OUR SCHOOLS, WE TEACH
THEM TO HATE OUR HISTORY AND
REVILE OUR RICHEST TRADITIONS.
THIS ALMOST END.
REBUILDING OUR ECONOMY REQUIRES
BECOMING INDEPENDENT OF DESPOTIC
REGIMES, LOVING OUR COUNTRY, AND
IT MEANS RETURNING TO THE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE OF THE TRUMP ERA.
IT'S TIME FOR BIDEN TO EXILE
JOHN KERRY TO WHEREVER HE GOES
ALL YEAR.
AS WE JUST HEARD FROM
PETER DOOCY, CONGRESS IS GOING
TO BE GETTING A REQUEST FOR
$6.4 BILLION IN EMERGENCY
FUNDING FOR UKRAINE.
THEY WILL HAVE TO PRINT OR
BORROW THAT MONEY.
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW EXACTLY DOES
MONEY WILL BE USED TO PUSH BACK
THE RUSSIANS OR GET HUMANITARIAN
HELP ALLEVIATING UKRAINIAN
SUFFERING, THOSE QUESTIONS MUST
BE RAISED NOW AND ANSWERED.
IN OTHER WORDS, WILL SPENDING
THIS MONEY BE -- CAMPAIGNING A
HOUSE WITH A HUGE HOLE IN THE
ROOF?
>> THE SITUATION IN UKRAINE IS
HEARTBREAKING AND INFURIATING,
BUT IT WAS NOT INEVITABLE.
BIDEN'S WEAK PRESIDENCY
CONTROLLED BY THE CLIMATE CHANGE
CROWD HELPED CREATE THE TRAGEDY
UNFOLDING IN UKRAINE TONIGHT.
AS LONG AS CHINA GIVES THEM
FINANCIAL CUSHIONS TO BLOCK
SANCTIONS, PUTIN IS GOING TO
HAVE H